takes a a looks forced to my eyes rook
takes a eight and notice that the rook
and queen are both on the open files and
Maurice you've got some highlights to
share well in this position the computer
agreed with comps Keys decision to get
back in the pond right away to play a5
and it's will a rook aid and now the
critical move is do not trade one of the
things that players often do is trade
thinking that it's just the thing you
should do but in this position that's
saying drop the rook back a 4 or a 2 so
that black doesn't dominate those files
and it says white and he has played rook
a to black will not be able to dominate
those files now and it says black has
absolutely no advantage maybe a small
smidgen of a point zero three hundredths
that is of a pawn and it just thinks the
game is fine for white guys I I still
don't understand the concept of what the
computers recommendation which was made
by Ramirez it still looks to me that
after the move rook e8 this is the big
difference Ramirez has spotted he can
play the move rook be one attacking
counter attacking the Queen he didn't
have to move his Queen after the trade
of Queens rook takes rook takes both
players have active rooks but check this
out
this pawn on d6 is much better protected
than this pawn on d3
still after King f8 or actually got it
did play Bishop f6 gada has ideas of
efore and Bishop D for bringing the
bishop to a dominating central square I
don't know I still like goddess position
even though he's not Material ahead
Maurice what do you think well we know
the move of the championships yes what
is it . g4 she's the [ __ ] right now for
pressuring the pawn on f5 but more
importantly threatening the move g5 and
so if g4 if you play E for in response
still g5 and white is totally in the
game
after this move incredible we've seen
this move we keep highlighting it and it
shows up in this position will he find
this really spectacular resource G for
staying fully in the game and getting
closer to that possibility of a juror
and the Armageddon game that's right G
for in the end game we talked about how
in last game got a can't use D for gain
more winning chances and now it looks
like it's a an equalizing idea for
Ramirez but I gotta tell you it goes to
show how rook and Bishop can outplay
rook and Knight that white White's under
pressure to find this only move G for
anything else and he for is this super
strong move I'm leasing that Bishop
which can also come to d4 and he don't
have to exactly so Ramirez probably
didn't realize that the physician was
drifting into the kind of game where he
has to play not just only moves but
actually desperate move move g4 you know
it's very easy to miss and the pressure
is on him now to come up with this
really spectacular move g4 not a common
thing in this type of position for white
to have to face as tables turn advantage
in my opinion still lies with Kamsky
regardless of what the computer thinks
g4 is not an easy move to play but then
again what else
that's right g4 he's certainly got to
consider whether there's that kind of a
play it and him g5 is the is a tricky
thing to see not g4 will come to his
mind freeing himself up and trying to
break up those two beautiful pressuring
pawns but seeing g5 that being said look
at how much Ramirez is thinking remember
in the last game when you thought he
really needed to find that critical move
he came to f6 which he found and he did
it for the first time in the game he
took a few minutes and he found it and
it looks like he might be doing the very
same thing in this game well g6 of
course also check this out gen 3 g4
we're anticipating g4 and then how's
this for a lineup
efore attacking Knight g5 attacking the
bishop bishop goes to c3
now what black is secretly hoping is
that there will be a trade of pawns on
e4 so the bishop could drop back to d4
attacking the pawn on a tf2 but this
spectacular moved g6 threatening back
rank mate and in case of H takes Knight
g5 White's doing well he did not play G
for City play worked to be a check and
after a king to f7 he worked a b7 Jack
and now of course a god I could just go
back to G ape and instead what about
coming up to g6 well king g6 then I'm
again I'm guessing that g4 is the move
but what other moves are there for white
because this this threat dispositional
threat of efore unleashing the bishop
allowing black to pose the fish upon d2
that would be lights out Maurice what do
you think well the check inserting the
check is not favorable and off in the
computer's eyes King g6 should be played
now and by the king being up in the
position it's preventing the move g5
from occurring it just seems as though
all Ramirez did was improve the position
of the black King you didn't need this
King to be in the game as well the guy
already has great pieces now the black
king is dynamic aggressive we know in
the endgame kings belong up the board
but instead gada has backed his king up
to e8 very surprising move King g6 was
perfectly fine but the game goes on
that's right the game goes on if the
game is a draw we've got that arm again
in bidding match we had a couple
questions about that will there be an
increment yes we don't want to see blitz
determining the US Champion yeah
now five-second increment is rather fast
that being said but it's not the same as
having your flags actually fall in the
winning or losing position and I do
think the players are trading
inaccuracies at this
all right moment played and I know it
looks like Ramirez has
with his rook probably ah okay so here
his idea for working one yes ice lady
for rookie one and thanks to that series
of checks the black king has been placed
on the e-file so white no longer has to
worry about having to move his knight
and it looks like black simply loses
upon that's why that move King g6 was so
critical and I really and very natural
yeah I gotta saw something that he
didn't like the King g6 sure look like
the right move and gada has played King
d7 after rook b1 again setting up that
threat of efore I think we can see g5
well what has he played he's played he
paid work to do you want to d1 okay so
the ideal player is that he can meet the
movie for with trades trades Knight to
d2 and Bishop d4 can simply be met with
by the calm Knight takes but is that so
clear rook comes to e2 and doesn't black
have something going on that's true so
even though we want a pawn you're gonna
win it back because we can't play f3 it
spin right so rook to d1 in the words of
the people of the Northwest seizing the
defensive I really don't like this from
Ramirez
I do believe God is pressing once again
a technical game Maurice
share your thoughts I agree with you yes
to see the move rook to B 1 to d1
certainly doesn't inspire confidence
when you know you should be playing
actively in the endgame maybe it's not
enough but for black to win but you've
got to feel like God is thinking YUM
thank you for just freezing your own
pieces when I wasn't even forcing you to
so I think right here Ramirez has really
made the task that's not that much
harder for himself and God has played h5
ruling out g4 for a long time to come
Wow what
instructive move considering how often
we've been finding g4 to be the saving
grace here for right each fight just as
you mentioned in when Ramirez was back a
move that he would have tried to get an
it Sofia frame g4 exactly the idea is
simply to gain space of course and
furthermore with the pawn now on h5 it
makes his own ideas of g5g for playable
so advantages for black if he can do
that on the other hand just because if
we want if I dare go back one move
captures efore captures captures I
actually did prefer this line of play
for gada as we'll see in a moment after
Knight takes rook totally force could we
hold off on that move for one okay
because you're gonna play III to a
strong effect
exactly exactly that the idea from from
blacks point of view is that now we are
getting some moves yes he did play h5
let's just jump into the game because
this is getting exciting after h5 what
happened next
g4 anyway g4 anyway our favorite move
Wow
that precipitated H take G H takes cheat
and Ramirez is dreaming that he will be
able to play Knight h2 and recapture
here on g4 keeping his pawn under
protection Maurice
actually yes it's Knight 2 d2 that the
computer favors one of those positional
games positional blockades that you are
you're famous for that I would hate to
have to try to break down so Knight - D
- is the money idea against this capture
on g4 and then suddenly he would have a
great position for his knight on e4 gada
has avoided that with the movie 4 ok
efore very forcing line of play we would
expect takes on e4 takes on e4
should I get in this move g5 now or
after Knight d2 Bishop d4 Knight takes
rook yeah rookie to again planning on
winning back the this pawn on f2 I still
like blacks chances in this position I
don't know what the times are Jennifer
we've got a maid here up on the screen a
big time advantage for Ramirez wow
that's that's surprising considering
he's under so much pressure
yeah and but okay the positions
favorable for geta I believe it's still
at this moment I've turned I
deliberately turned off my engine so I
can put myself in the player shoes and
understand the the computer oftentimes
interferes with I may miss a tactic help
me dear audience if I do miss a tactic
but efore and Ramirez has to come up
with the right move here and he has
played something it looks like g5 no she
actually took on e4 first yes he took on
e4 and comes up on g4 got a recaptured
with capturing on g4 well that's a big
surprise and this big-time move e5 I
like that move by Ramirez and that was
actually critical I think because after
a night h2 what would have happened
after Knight h2 perhaps a simple move
like g3 takes rook c2 going at or even
rookie two going after these pawns on e4
or c4 black would win his pawn back with
the superior game so Ramirez properly
played the move e4 e5 and I'm sure he
got it was disgusted that Ramirez found
this key move at this crucial moment of
game two in the playoffs there
instructive move when we saw something
similar earlier to trying to blunt the
power of the bishop and using that
in-between move that swishing joke right
so impact uh Kamsky took that night on
f3 very real can't be immediately
recapturing on f6 very reluctantly had
to allow the trade of his beautiful
bishop for that night takes on f3 takes
on f6
rook d3 I am absolutely sure Ramirez is
now eyeballing this pawn what has he
done instead oh my goodness huh okay I
assume he didn't want to see rook to f3
r up to d3 rook takes variations I'm not
quite a calculated perhaps after-effects
e4 rook to c4 maybe he felt that the C
pawn was more dangerous than his F pawn
a very reasonable judgment to be sure he
did in fact play rook to c1 protecting
against that idea and maybe he's just
setting up for rook c3 King coming over
here and trying to round up this pawn
that's right and what do you think of
this pastor defense actually well the
computer loves his moves Ramirez is
playing like a genius I mean his defense
is the defensive posture maybe dubious
in our eyes but just the way he's
playing with such amazing precision
defensively he's like a rock-solid bull
saying come get me and see what's going
to happen
it's incredible I'm really appreciating
this guy's technique and he's so calm
and he's doing it so quickly are these
clock times correct can't be right 18
minutes to seven minutes
many Dave Kamsky a look with that move
rook to c3 I wonder if they're what that
means well just at the board you know
yeah at times its inadvertent you're not
trying to stare but you know you do you
can't help but you got a flash a look at
your opponent oh yes yes
yeah if it
see if your opponents at ease or looking
a little bit nervous but this move rooks
III now after the inclusion the move f7
f5 makes a great deal of sense for white
because he's hoping to capture on f3
restoring the material balance and then
capturing on f6
know if we're k4 in this position hoping
that after a work takes f3 we can take
on c4 and transpose to similar
variations alejandro can play this king
h2 and round off the pawns with a king
instead and of course the king being a
really key piece again and at this point
exactly and so instead I think I to
played something else Grandmaster
Maurice Ashley actually seems God has
not moved as yet his time still ticking
down we should note got him on four
games in a row then he drew five in a
row in the main event and then he just
drew another game and this one is
looking like yet another draw quite
possibly it is very close the computers
giving virtually no edge to gada here
0.23 God has got to be getting a little
frustrated what do I have to do to win a
game again have I well has he ever gone
a week in the US Championships without
winning a game pretty interesting maybe
frustrating situation for him right now
and his youthful opponent seems very
confident flicking out the moves
not at all intimidated by this
three-time champion that's right and it
does look like we're nearing our
Armageddon playoff and as we know that
what we include a secret bidding process
so you can go to US chess champ calm
regulations if you're at all confused
because it can be tricky to understand
at first basically they're gonna bid to
see who gets black pieces and draw odds
the other player will get more time and
white
whoever bids lower will get black and
draw odds right so we saw in the 2010 US
Championship playoff between Schulman
and Kamsky Kamsky bid and extremely low
about 25 minutes and this was actually a
game 60 so he bid 25 minutes you're even
something like 40 minutes right and so
of course god I got black drawers in 25
minutes you already got the full 60 and
the white pieces in this case it would
be 45 minutes or the player who gets
white I see and I think
their bids will actually be kind of
close to 25 to 30 minutes and we'll have
to see who thinks that being black is
more important just to retain those draw
odds of course got a Kamsky with six
draws in a row as Maurice pointed out
might think that he should be really
well he seems to be drawing a lot of
dams well it it's amazing what a week
makes when we started the championship
it was the camp's he expressed just
writing over people for zero
lots of chitter chatter on our set about
the Bobby Fischer prize $64,000 for a
perfect score I was discussing this with
a lot of my colleagues and I was saying
no no no it's so hard so difficult to
put together that many wins I didn't see
it as being possible and sure enough now
we're looking at a god of camp ski who
has to win just to win the US
Championship never mind a perfect score
kingi 7 was played by gada and
immediately rookie six III check King f6
rook e6 check I don't know if this is
the I was playing the right drawing
procedure from White's point of view
White's King is very passive in this
line of play
maybe Ramirez just thinks that this line
is a draw for example well thank you
rook c6
rook takes d6 maybe after rook d4 rook
takes rook takes black is a merge with
an extra pawn but those doubled F pawns
are not as meaningful as for example if
that f5 pawn was on the e4 square we can
bring our work around to check you're
not going to be able to actually invade
with your own king right after you pawn
guards against it coming to the key g3
where I'm a little bit of a head of the
players at the moment rook c2 is on the
board rook takes d6 maybe we could see
another funny line almost the difference
here remember that previous game the
first game where the rook wasn't
at the pond that in this case blacks
King has the nearly ideal f4 square in
which to hide behind so for example just
to continue this line for a moment rook
takes d6 king f4 d7 rook d4
there's no ideas of moving the rook with
a check because that pawn on f5 properly
hides shelters the black King right
shouldering that King similar to the
other game where the King was on Essex
with a pawn on f7 that's right
so rook see - the reason why I didn't
well okay I shouldn't go too far
backwards but I didn't see any thing
specifically wrong earlier with rook
takes f3 King f6 rook III and then going
after this d6 pawn just getting rid of
one tooth on the f3 pawn daddy didn't
happen we do have a another movie and it
looks like got a 100 or just played work
to c6 okay we would we would certainly
expect rook takes e4 in this case d6
again and Ramirez probably thinking that
this position is a draw still gotta on
the sunny side of the torture as we
would say well earlier yes Alejandro had
to find some good moves but Maurice your
thoughts on this finale here dead draw
no chance for anything how do you make
any progress with black your King can't
get into the position you really can't
get to the F pawn it's it's got to be a
draw no it just looks like Ramirez knows
it calms keep sitting there for a long
time if he thought that this position
held some promise he would have moved
already I think I think he thinks not
again the guy holding a rook pawn with
accuracy as he just blocked the last
game and now his head is in his hands
I think he realizes it Ramirez has
figured out yet another way to draw by
the way they play they have now played
this their fourth game
two classical games one in the last
championship comes Ramirez had black and
was crushed by calm ski and the black
side of a Sicilian con then this year
with the fantastic Bishop h3 move that
that Ramirez shocked him with and now
sort of like in both games Ramirez is
saying you you're not beating me from
some reason you just can't beat me now
and he's he's like he's running up
against a brick wall in Ramirez very
confident and I think we're going to see
the Armageddon game because there's just
not much to play for in this position
Wow I'm just so impressed by Ramirez
he's playing like amateur veteran
instead of a on his maiden voyage in the
playoffs of the US Championships never
played a playoff like this before
he's acquitting himself marvelously oh
that's right and what are your
predictions for this bidding process how
low do you think they will go boy I
really have to put my thinking cap on we
do have a move by God a Kamsky he did
play whoa do I got this right
he didn't capture the pawn which we
thought was an automatic he jumped in
with king f4 he gotta is calculating a
very forcing line now he's thinking that
I will go after this f2 pawn I'm going
to give you two connected passed pawns
but I'll have wonderful plate with the
pawn on f3 so let's just take a look at
the possible lines that God a camp ski
has calculated it's probably no he's not
taking any risk with this decision at
all Maurice am i right Wow
well it looked yeah that's that's a
different move and he did not have to
play that but the move rook takes c5
looked easy actually rook takes e5 rook
c1 check king h2 rook over pawn up and
then after rook takes pawn just bring
your king back right and there's no
progress there's that the pawn is not
helping this D pawn is very strong and
black just doesn't have the time to get
his F pawn and the
he wants if for example rook to c2 here
since rook to d2 would be handsome by
rogue d5 then just rook down to c8 and
no progress possible for black he just
cannot shelter his position so nothing
was in that position but it looks like
Kamsky ramirez played rook aged six and
Counting he came back to g5 and that
looks within tolerance as well that's
right so work age six just again with
the idea of a score so instead of even
bothering to calculate those lines
Ramirez just trying to hold the balance
with work eight six and got a compelled
to play King back to g5 right Kim can't
make any progress because of the f2 pond
and then Ramirez his crits gonna shoot
his rook back to c6 it appears right and
that would force a repetition and then
well that's all taking place I'm still
processing what I might did that's right
in the Armageddon it's I haven't given
an answer I'm just I never got into I I
got into lots of lots of playoffs over
Mike the course of my career and I feel
myself very experienced but it was an
innovation here at the st. Louis chess
club that they introduced this auction
and I love it that is really really an
intriguing idea and silent secret
auction Madeline yes a secret bidding
not an open bid exactly exactly and the
audience I'm expecting you to help me
what would you bid because frankly I
don't know I really don't know I have
ideas Maurice you have ideas indeed a
couple of moves have been playing rook a
chain we should get back to this board
before I even say anything let them let
the game go on and let's stay abreast
and I'll give my opinion afterwards so
yes where Kate was playing Rick takes e4
rook h8 rook takes e4 d6 rook c5 I am
anticipating the straightforward rook c8
did play it needed going after this pawn
on c5 got that position on the board and
gata Kamsky on move rook takes d6 it
takes e5 and even though gada is a pawn
head it shouldn't offer him any winning
chances after precise moves like rook
check provoking the pawn to move to f4
and I think let me just be a hundred
percent sure about this I can either
come back and I don't see how black
could progress or I could try to go for
the active and with rook here now this
didn't happen but after work c4 check
instead of f4 god I camps me played King
to age three so that's the position we
have now on the ward
okay excuse me for check teenage three
and Alejandro to play well when being
faced with matin one there's only one
move to play one was played and now gata
Kamsky quickly playing work g6 check
with ideas of work G - yep King H -
exactly trying to get unto g1 if you
play to f1 if you go king h1 keeping the
king out it's important that you don't
play the move rook F 1 here because
after rook F 1 F 4 it's Zook swung on
the board so you'd have to play rook C -
and unless I'm missing some clear
winning idea here for black I see a draw
Maurice the move King h1 is forced by
the way he must play this move King f1
instantly loses to king h2 and the game
is over so he shouldn't be thinking now
his fans would not be happy if he moves
the King exit stage left that's going to
be awful because now he would actually
have to deal with this mate threat he'd
have to play king he won and then the
trade of rooks and of course it's over
right in that position so he must now
play King h1 and he has done so and rook
down though rook to c2 and no problems
at all because there's no way to really
make progress in this position if he
just moves his work up and he has done
so this is still well within tolerance a
dead draw and by the way the King
White's King is currently in stalemate
we should note that so if white could
somehow sack his rook if the King drops
back for example a let line you're
showing there yes
some kind of rucksack and it's a
stalemate so so cop speed has to be real
careful about his next move in fact I
think his rooks gonna have to just leave
I don't think you can leave his rook on
that square you think you can't make any
progress it's just stuck and Ramirez is
eyeing him and you could see if he knows
this is a draw no way you make even with
in all those moves you play well you say
all rook endings are drawn this is what
they mean this kind of thing and there
it is his rook has left the area
not wanting to steal me you know Jen I
think we've been here ten days almost
two weeks we've shown well let's say
hundreds of different styles of
checkmate we finally found our first
stalemate that's right we haven't found
too many beautiful sail mates you got it
and there was one rook see - we tried
King g4 and we demonstrated the one
stalemate in order to avoid that
stalemate
what Maurice was mentioning White's King
is absolutely stuck in the corner
got it did drop back with his rook why
he chose the g7 square no idea he could
have chose the g8 g6 no difference
between g7 and g8 I know just a matter
of taste I would suppose I would expect
rook c3 saying hey let me take away your
soul advantage that extra double pawn
and if the King dropped back hey let me
just chase you a little bit backwards
and we're back to it back to c3 also
part of me or you can just play back to
think or back to c3 with the rook as you
mentioned that looks absolutely
stone-cold draw now we can start to
discuss the bidding procedure alright
and they probably are contemplating the
bidding procedure right now and I think
Grandmaster Maurice Ashley's got a bit
in mind I don't think they're
contemplating anything right now exactly
this game gets over properly but you
know last time when we did the
commentary together Jen we saw calm
Skiba 25 minutes as you mentioned with
60 minutes in the clock I was stunned so
25 minutes is he crazy but it ended up
working out for him so I anticipate with
now at 45 minutes cops need to go as low
as 20 maybe
eighteen minutes in his bed I think he
wants those black pieces and he thinks
showing how he's drawing easily with
black he's always the one with the
initiative a black that he doesn't
believe he could lose with the black
pieces and he said it himself so far I'm
playing great with black and horrible
with white so he wants to win the bid
and not have to play badly with white
again and end up drawing the game and
losing the championship
I had agree with that but I think
something like 18 might be a little low
um he might feel like it's obviously a
gamble you might vote if he does 22
he'll win the bid anyway
and get those extra precious four
minutes but we will find out soon it
seems we've got some of these moves on
the board work to see for track f4 has
been played I would anticipate well just
hanging around and asking what are you
gonna do he instead ramírez that is
instead brought his rook to the
eighth-ranked anticipating that he'd be
able to force a number of checks against
Blacks King and his King his own King
will be released King at 5:05 was placed
these double pawns
still still Ramirez has to find some key
moves here I mean it's very it's still
very easy for him to go wrong I'm not
sure I like this move rook c8 in fact if
we go back just before example of them
going wrong well I'm thinking that white
should have just tethered right whacks
King to this pawn so for example just
saying go ahead keep keep doing whatever
it is that you want to do and only after
the rook has made a commitment to the f1
square do you drop back with the rook
I'm thinking that this would have been
the easiest way the reason why is
because in the game position after this
move look how easy it is for you to for
white pardon me to go wrong imagine a
rook check King comes here another rook
check and you're thinking okay I'm just
I'm just gonna lollygag around
well the rook would come to F
- and rook would come to g2 I'd beg your
pardon
and actually win this pawn on f2 and
that would just simply be a dreadful
consequence actually yes I'm sorry yeah
you'd be retail meeting again and maybe
then you could check keep checking in
that position I keep for you're not
rookie 3 check of course which would
which would be a disaster but rook d6
check and again where does the king hide
rook d2 check and it's a stalemate ah
well not quite you're right this capture
oh there you'll rook f1 again and if the
King moves and rook takes a free and
there we go this oh no but he could play
a rook you can maybe play rook check in
that position no rook H to check is
winning in that position actually rook
h2 and King takes King takes rook so
yeah you could easily go wrong
ezal it yeah that's nasty
so the King coming over at the other way
making the threat to get the F pawn much
more dangerous and they were in and and
he has lead your move rook to c3 but now
they can come into e4 look-see for track
whoa rook c4 check are you sure because
I'm seeing King e2 king d3 to eat III
was playing and Ramirez may have blown
it oh my goodness
because it except for Cammy - is a bit
of a problem huh
not a bit of a problem major major
development what happened on the board
happened now he played work to a4 King
tf2 occured work to eight work to a -
check this qg3 this is a draw by Wi-Fi
miracle well the book draw because he
has rook G to check curve hey move rook
G - well known and got oh look at that
we finally got our stalemate rather no
now our second stalemate yeah well our
Sammy oh they actually occurred not just
a variation
Wow this is a well-known stalemate from
11 fish Smith's love meaning that he's
falling for it God is laughing because
I'm sure when he played the move rook b7
he thought got him and we have a draw
and the Armageddon match is imminent
oh yeah fan
I mean friend and fan now can't help but
smile there Wow but everybody was
smiling that uh this is very exciting
finale a shout out to our audience let's
take a poll guys and gals what would you
bid if you were god of camps in knowing
that you've just drawn five six games in
a row
I think seven game seven games in a row
you're unstoppable but you haven't been
able to win you want the black pieces
how low would you bid I'm still clueless
I still don't want to commit myself
until I see the results of our poll we
do have some audio from the playing hall
with a executive director and arbiter
Tony rich she's the assistant arbiter
Frank whadda Lupe explaining the bidding
process
well and now they're thinking about
their bids you'd wonder if also maybe
the outcome of the games today the
openings and the results might even
affect it further perhaps last night
they were thinking I'll bid X but now we
see two draws and the games involving a
lot of early trades and great defenses
by black maybe it went a bit even lower
right right and I and I it makes sense
that there would have to be written bits
as well right yes written bids and then
the orbiters were open both of them and
the bid that is lower will get the black
pieces and draw odds so for instance if
Ramirez bids twenty minutes and got a
camps new bids what Maury suggested
eighteen minutes
Dada cam scoop we will get 18 minutes
black and draw odds ramirez's time will
revert to 45 minutes so got it so the
player has the white pieces will always
have 45 minutes plus the 5 seconds
exactly and the player has the black
pieces gets the time that he bid upon
but also the 5 seconds right so that's
pretty big too so that's why they can go
as low as 18 minutes 20 minutes because
you are gonna get that 5 second
increment which is a pretty key and as
you see today both players playing well
and quickly and not letting the nerves
get to them and get really low on time
may encourage them to bid even lower
than they had planned to perhaps last
night Maurice your thoughts he is doing
is playing well he is missing one movers
that idea with rook g2 leading to a
stalemate that's basic stuff he knows
that from his days as a
as a teenager back in Russia that that
was just way too easy for him to miss
and then sudden he's looking up laughing
because he's missing move after move
that's the second big move that Ramirez
has played a remember that move Bishop
h3 from the from their classical game
that they played
I think gada is a little bit off right
now and with less time on the clock
especially dramatically less he might
just miss a move in the next time
control in Ramirez how confident does he
look effortlessly
okay maybe not effortlessly but so
smooth relaxed even in worse positions
defending incredibly well pulling
rabbits out of his hat I think that it's
to his advantage right now in this
situation I got to think the underdog
has a puncher's chance to win this
championship absolutely although we
should point out that Ramirez was on the
defensive with the white pieces so okay
got a Kamsky out playing him in the
opening stage and making Ramirez really
fight tooth and nail for that draw and
then in the end the question is could
black have won because I mean how could
you have really differed with this
uh.this against this idea I don't think
he could have won well there's not
necessarily missus go meat so much is
like he tried his best and Ramirez found
the right defense exactly well that's
not really the right defense because the
right as you would have said would maybe
not even to let the King enter in this
direction right that hold on to that
pawn on f3 unless Ramirez was so
confident about this end game he wanted
to play it for the fans but I find that
highly doubtful exactly I don't think
anybody wants to play the white side
because any misstep could lose the game
and he's just feeling as preppy preppy
and as happy as possible because the
underdog has gotten himself into an
Armageddon game I'm still anxious to
know what you would bid here it comes
if I were in Ramirez a shoes I would bid
25 and if God a bid 20 I would want to
play the white pieces I take the 45
minutes I take the extra time I like
being forced to play for a win
especially when my opponents down
the clock I believe that you were right
I think that it is more likely to win
this bid I think we also are going to
see something similar to what you say
Alejandro of course doesn't want to bid
too high because then if God attempts
keep it something like thirty you really
have hurt himself immensely we see a lot
of other players from the championship
and grandmasters Grandmaster Josh Vidal
in the audience the young Sarah Chang
who had a nice finish to her tournament
and Anna sure of it she interviewed a
couple times in the show women's
Grandmaster from Belarus studying in
Lindenwood so the audience here at the
st. Louis chess club is getting really
excited both the live audience and those
watching at the World Chess Hall of Fame
I'm sure those of you watching at home
are thrilled I can't wait to see what
these two guys bid we are gonna take a
quick break and we're gonna find out
both the bids and in just a couple of
hours the US Chess Champion don't go
away
welcome to Armageddon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay Tony
[Music]
okay you have a hand of 100 Ramirez said
he is willing to start with 19 minutes
and 40 seconds kada 20 minutes in the
middle
so he gets 1940 with five second
increments get against 45 40
19 minutes
yep ii got it yep okay 20 needs two
minutes to set up the names what is the
garam
you got to Elliot
Tony
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the 2013 u.s.
chess championship playoffs I'm Jen
jihadi I'm with Grandmaster jasser Sara
Juan and Maurice Ashley we are in the
army Denon deathmatch here for the 2013
title and we have some interesting bids
here we were thinking that gada Kamsky
was going to get black pieces and draw
lots because of his aggressive bid back
in 2010 against yours Shulman when he
bid 25 minutes almost half of what his
opponent made this time Ramirez
outfitting by just 15 seconds 1945 where
as camp's new bid 20 minutes
that gives Ramirez the black pieces and
draws odds by just a hair and we are
seeing the same opening as we saw in
their first name absolutely c5 which I
got to play g3 in this position and
didn't get too much with g3 I'm sure
he's gonna go for d5 because he's in a
must-win situation
I know Maurice has got a lot of thoughts
to share about the bidding process
Maurice well I thought personally that
Ramirez has tricked Kamsky yet again
imagine you bid 20 minutes and the guy
says 1945 that means he got inside your
head thought you might be 20 and let me
just shave a little bit so I can catch
you out there so caps key must be
thinking yet again what the heck this
kid just keeps escaping one way or the
other
when I'm trying to get something done
and so now calm skis forced to win with
white he was not he I has not been
playing well with with the white pieces
and he hasn't won a game in seven tries
this has got a calm ski three-time champ
against a much lower rated opponent not
saying any advantage for either side
here but Ramirez has to be feeling yet
another boost of morale that's
interesting although I do think this bid
is a little low it's very risky master
Alejandro Ramirez with a huge time
deficit and if I've got a succeeds in
getting an edge with white and
complicating the position it's gonna be
extremely difficult for Ramirez to find
all the right defenses with so much less
time on the clock no he does still have
those bikes I can increment so that will
help if he gets to an endgame agreed all
around my only
comment would be that I actually like
the situation that gada has found
himself in he knows he has a must-win
situation and he knows that he's got a
big time edge so he's going to be
looking for a type of battle where the
the critical moments come later in the
game and we do have yes exactly and we
have the same opening that we saw in
round one of their playoff and again god
I repeated with this move c4 I just
suspected he didn't play it I suspected
that he might go
efore and go into a kind of open
Sicilian or Sicilian dragon even if you
will with a fianchetto he did play see
for a repeat we saw in Game one this
move by Ramirez Queen c7 provoked that
move Knight a three and he was repeated
the same idea and again they the players
are repeating game one move for move d7
d6 has been played like a lot psychology
here by Ramirez he already labored over
these moves so he can play them pretty
quickly and gain a little bit of time on
his clock with a five-second increment
that being said we kind of liked White's
position in that game didn't we yes a
smidgen but again a very mm normal shall
we say slight disadvantage for black
that Ramirez kept the position
throughout very cagey play by Ramirez
and now gada has to think well if I
repeat game one with my b2 b3
how will I gain an edge over what
happened in Game one I didn't really see
it where there was any major misstep
where he had any major opportunity I
mean to say forgot it so when you're
when you're the defender you play your
number one defense until it's broken and
it hasn't been broke it wasn't broken in
game 1
well let's see where these guys differ
now it's it's a goddess turn he's the
first one who seems to be thinking
although we'll probably see a lot of
that in this match because God of course
started the game with twice as much time
as his opponent over twice as much time
see that maurice thoughts this this
business about having a time advancement
I think is so deceptive because when you
stop and think you could easily fritter
away this advantage the minutes just
tick away he's you're busy thinking what
are the winning lines and we saw this
before when Schulman wasn't able to
crash through against Kamsky in their
matchup two years ago that he kept
playing more and more aggressively
now this Garry Kasparov showed the way
when he played against Anatoly Karpov in
a critical matchup it's and you have to
win it's best to prolong the battle
going and going and let the time tick
away don't look for advantage you don't
need it just keep hitting an even bigger
advantage on the clock let his clock
tick down to like five minutes and you
keep your 25 simple moves so I for any
forcing lines just keep making moves
don't let the clock times equalize at
all don't let it ever come close and
you'll find that the clock alone will be
your friend and your opponent will start
to blunder Jenin yes we have some some
questions coming in at 1/2 New York can
screen Ramirez playing further player
gets 20k or the if Ramirez draws the
game of course he will also another
prize and the US Championship title and
it's the prestige of the title trust me
that is even worth more than the $10,000
nice payday for both that gotta Kamsky
he has to find a way of putting the
pressure on Ramirez and forcing the
young man to think and use up his clock
obviously God as big as a lie at this
particular moment is the clock so he's
got if he's got to figure out a way of
putting problems that Ramirez had well
happy that God is desperate or anything
of that nature after Knight takes b5
Queen takes e4 I'm sure the computer
thinks this is just absolutely marvelous
for the second player however we see a
lot of these sacrifice in Catalan
openings and I was just looking at a
physician after queen C for the Queen
takes e4 pardon me the Queen drops back
to c5 white gets an a powerful
initiative for the pawn
perhaps it Peters out with this move
Bishop e3 I'm angling for rook c1
attacking the Queen and night c7 winning
the trap rook in the corner it probably
is a bad idea that it's at least
something that would force let's show
that one more time let's go back and I'm
just saying this is the position at the
board and I've got in difficulties
thinking difficulties I mean to say this
sacrifice well is it worth the punt and
not a hundred percent sure but it's it
would really mix things up tremendously
wouldn't it oh that's right and put her
where be right under a lot of pressure
and you want to give out our chests calm
membership of the day and that goes to
gingy fan who asked us during a round or
earlier playoffs the the rapid games
there's a rapid format favor of the
youth so gingy fan congratulations on
winning a chest comm membership got any
other questions or comments a hashtag us
chest champs so as we get deeper into
this game they're gonna have to be
really good to get a mountain and what
was the poll what was the poll did the
poll come in at 20 oh we got a few
different answers and I also think we
have a Maurice with some thoughts on
this opening so far already well yes I
think that the secret here for calm ski
actually is not to play aggressively is
not to come up with some big problem
solving issues what does what does black
have to do in this position to get out
of the mind it's called a buy-in for a
reason right black normally cannot get
out of it at will unless white does
something to attack so I'm thinking what
if calm ski stays put for a very long
time you know the kind of position I'm
talking about he plays he plays his
pieces out and then he puts a rook on do
you wanna rock on c1 then he puts the
rook on d1 back to e1 and then that rook
on so you want to e 1 plus h3 plays
King h2 he backs up he probes a little
bit pretty soon because white doesn't
have anything the black doesn't have
anything to do black stars gonna be
staring at five minutes on the clock and
the person who has no time would you
really want to play gotta calm ski
thirty minutes to five minutes knowing
you have to draw in the next five
minutes you're gonna do something and
the one thing you cannot do is something
that opens the position when whites
pieces are all stopping all the breaks
so I I think that it's it may seem
counterintuitive but it's not really
incumbent on white to try to win it's in
it's incumbent on on black to make the
draw more so so whites adjust because of
the time only only because of this big
time edge white should just chill and
freeze black for as long as possible
and I think this is the position to do
it I think you're right Maurice and you
see a lot of experts in playing in their
opponents time pressure do the same
thing great if you play a tactical line
hey that's exactly what your opponent in
time pressure is thinking about if you
make a quiet move suddenly they're like
whoa I didn't prepare for that and their
time gets eaten up and then when the
game really intensifies they could be in
horrible time pressure true but again
what Maurice is trying to say is let's
keep a lot of the pieces on the board
let's defer the critical moments the
battle till later when Black has blacks
time has been ticking down and it's just
not so easy to do that in my view black
has a very key or clear idea pardon me
he wants to trade the pieces with knight
c6 Knight takes d4
so if gada takes maurices advice and
wants to keep the pieces maybe he should
just go over here immediately with 94 to
b5 attacking the Queen forcing the Queen
either to back up to d8 and then later
in life bring the knight back to a3 when
chased because otherwise this plan of
Ramirez that we saw in Game one was very
effective a six-night c6 trade a lot of
pieces he made a draw
not so completely comfortably that it
was easy for him to play and yes that is
the kind of move I'm talking about a
move we may not play normally but you
know what you're trying to do keep the
pieces on the board so suddenly you have
a different mindset a different plan if
somebody sets the guy to come ski can
you keep the pieces on the board and not
let the guy break the position open
that's an easier job for him
then can you force a win right now or
give him like big time problems and look
at him he's starting to think how much
time does he have left the clock times
I'd be curious to know how much he's
investing in this moment it may be you
make this huge investment and come up
with nothing then you've just blown 10
minutes on the clock for what right you
know so I think I think this is a very
important moment for him and maybe he is
not playing well clearly he's not
playing with my strategy at all he's
looking for a way to push this position
home and I think it's a mistake not
necessarily he could be trying to plan
in advance so he can make his next few
moves quickly and keep the pressure on
Alejandro and try to induce mistakes
that might be a strategy because I think
in general he does share your philosophy
and we saw some of that in his
Armageddon match against Shulman where
he was actually playing with the black
side but I I think that he's got still a
comfortable time edge 34 minutes at this
point so we hope that he'll think up as
some been interesting to keep this this
battle going the US Chess Championship
here where if gata Kamsky wins you take
the title if I 100 Raw's or wins
you take the title exactly well let's
just see a potential variation 95 let's
say Queen d7 okay let's imagine Bishop
e3 as in gift meet the pawn 96 now let's
stop this and be cagey keep all the
pieces on the board with a move like h3
now we understand why the move Queen d7
was played to keep the knight protected
and after eight after b6 the idea from
blacks point of view is he wants to play
Bishop b7
Knight a5 or maybe 95 in order to trade
pieces God has got to figure out how he
can stop those trades and increase the
pressure it's tough with this night
sitting out here on the a3 square where
it's really not doing that much he could
drop back with the Knight to c3 Bishop
to b7 King HD I'm just putting some
moves on the board to try to keep as
many pieces on the board as possible
something like this where God a superior
positional judgment might come into the
for I think a queen on a4 at some point
in that variation it strange gata Kamsky
already covering his face with his hands
this is very strange is he signifying
that he regrets either his bid or his
opening choice we will find out soon and
he he played your move Yasser he played
night on D to b5 right and I mean again
this was what Maurice applauded this
move I understand it very well we 14 d8
by Ramirez a quick queen d8 by Ramirez
well goddamn aim may have had some
regrets that he thought so long on that
particular move whether his opponent
instantly responded with Queen d8 I'm
sure God it was more in the I'm
expecting you to play the 587 so then
Bishop g5 got his response and as you
point out a lot of times we're gonna
relocate a Knight to d5 that Bishop on
g5 will then be helping to and yes in
the earlier game we saw Bishop f6 Bishop
f6 Knight d5 giving like that that
slight edge with the better pawn
structure exactly and the play has begun
the tempo of play pardon me has begun to
get a little bit quicker white does have
the freer development and maybe gada is
angling for Bishop h6 or as Maurice is
suggested just keep as many pieces on
the board as possible which gada has
done successfully as this at this moment
a six and ninety-three blade
right well finally there's a little
something to be to work with now that a
six has been induced there comes ideas
of in the near future of maybe trying to
plant a night on b6 that's the first
let's say targeted area that God can
look at in blacks camp if you look at
blacks position like doesn't have any
real weakness on it's on the board that
you could say oh this is a terrible
thing I got to jump all over that and
only now has the first slight weakness
and what looks like a pretty fortified
position appeared and do we have any
moves after 93 no it looks like oh no
yeah he played Bishop he played Bishop
to f5 if I play - no gotta unmoving in
okay well we talked about the maracas
see vine made famous by a Hungarian
player in the 20th century gave Giza
Marchesa Baroque see he liked his pawns
on e4 and c4 trying to clamp down on the
d5 square with this move Bishop f5
Alejandro saying I'm going to give you
the morose C bind with a gain of a tempo
in order to cut that Bishop on g2 right
now it's an open diagonal obviously once
the pawn appears on e4 that diagonal is
closed but again gada might say well
give me whatever it is you want to give
me and if you drop back with your bishop
for example to e6 I want to jump to the
d5 square and put pressure on this
knight on f6 if you do capture I'll
capture with the e pawn and at least
white has some respectable advantage of
the two bishops that's right and some
pressure along the e file and not too
many trades allowing for a rich struggle
as he tries to make use of his time
advantage here
I think they that a Superbowl gata
Kamsky will indeed play easy for okay
any other suggestion be on e4 I mean
would you go for this Bishop h6 of try
to eliminate this Bishop on g7 and maybe
say to black
well your King is more vulnerable
once I've traded bishops I don't think I
would do that because we just recently
purpose one g5 it's kind of trying to
if6 and East 7 so I mean he's gonna stay
with that theme and we do have efore
played on the board and it looks like
Ramirez has backtracked to e6 another
pretty useful square for the Bishop the
natural and 95 is what we're expecting
now we got a can't ski again threatening
to fracture Ramirez as pawns which we
saw in the first game of this match
Dada Kamsky got an advantage and Ramirez
defended a you know very very solidly in
order to score the draw on that game
these doubled F pawns is what happened
black structure got broken up a bit like
if I does look like it was played but it
were in this game not as easy for
Ramirez because if he gets such a
significant disadvantage then even with
enough defence of resources he's got the
time issue right and that is the number
one ally in the position for gotta camp
ski is the clock we don't want to harp
on that too much but okay Ghana has
something that is very tangible we
noticed once again why the square b6 is
weak black were to make a horrible fault
with a move like Queen d7 bang that's a
very nice fork and that would win an
exchange so Ramirez has probably got to
eliminate that knight on d5 he doesn't
want his pawns to get doubled on the F
line Maurice right Knights back to d7
did Ramirez Knight F to d7 which
according to the computer gives white a
slight edge and I think it's even bigger
than that psychologically because right
now comes he can just make a couple of
rook moves actually constantly has a
bunch of free moves it looks like to
make how does black get out of this bind
and he's going to have to figure
something out and the more that moves
play now with comps cubed all the pieces
on the board the mores didn't have a
chance to
force Ramirez who by the way is just
still moving at a an amazing pace but
sooner or later he's gonna run out of
moves in some critical moment and he's
gonna have to make a decision and the
moment you make a decision against the
bind sometimes is the moment you lose
the game so Kamsky with a very simple
rook move over to see one followed by
rook c8 and now b3 playing total power
control chess I know yes you're used to
this kind of chess
oh yeah I like this for white I have
always liked I'm a big fan but I've
always been a very big believer in space
and I love occupying the center
unlike nimzowitsch that didn't get a
rise out of class time though as I
understand we've got about 23 minutes
per gotta kenski and Ramirez haven't not
used that much of his initial investment
oh yeah they feel time yeah and it was
about 12 or 13 this move b3 does prepare
this knight on a 3 is the only hiccup I
would say in the position for white
white has to determine whether his
knight is best placed on c3 or maybe he
wants to go Knights e2 to b4 I rather
like the second idea of night c2 to be
for a little bit more but we do have a
move what Brooke fe8 Row 2 es 488 re
fortifying the pawn on e7 now I'm not
sure if gada would like to play rook F
e1 which I'm sure he would like to pay
play pardon me but maybe he thinks
bringing the knight in to play first
deferring the rook move is best Knight
c2 looks right to me but there's also
this night b1 move equally attractive
staking the knight on c3 one thing in
blacks favor by the way that I should
point out is black does have pretty good
control over this d4 square and gada has
to keep in mind that at some moment
black may return
the favor nice outpost for white tonight
potentially nice outpost for blacks
night on the d4 square by the way yes if
I may I think that I think that Ramirez
is clearly showing his hand play fast
play solid right play fast play solid
and I think calm skis should be doing
the exact same thing I loved your move
Knight to c2 but then again that b5
break we see that happen often as well
as something that he's trying to control
so he's in this control mode while
playing good moves but his last move I
think
looks like h3 was played and so there we
go again pure control chess he has to
make sure nothing no funny hiccups
happen along the way but I think he's on
the right track now and if Ramirez is
actually down to 12 minutes though it
doesn't seem like that much of an
investment it's 12 minutes that's not a
lot of time think for two minutes you
were attending for two more here at 8:00
and nothing's happening and you need a
draw so this is exactly where he wants
to be Ramirez any 32nd think is a big
percentage of his time so he's got to
watch himself right now and I don't know
that he can come up with anything in
this position to even suggest how to
draw the game he's going to be in heavy
time pressure if the if this stays like
this 10 minutes equal for each Ramirez
is gonna lose okay well that's bold
again I don't see any specific ly
anything specific that's wrong with the
black position I agree by the way I
don't think anything's wrong with black
really just the time situation against
the 15 for for Ramirez and 27 forgotten
now okay some incremental build up by
both players and it's the slow build
that Maurice wanted to see the cagey
veteran gata Kamsky been here done that
he knows what's at stake and he's just a
little postponing the battle postponing
the battle this last move h2 h3 needs a
little comment
after h2 h3 one of the things that this
square this move does it takes away the
g4 square but more importantly it just
prepares King H to wear when white
decides it's time to open things up with
the move f4 he wants his King nice and
safe so this is a fine preparatory move
for a move like King h2 to preface the
advance f4 we've seen a move by an ID to
e5 with the transferrin threat of Bishop
takes on h3 and then the fork on f3
would check so little threat there to
calm ski I'm sure he notices it yes well
he wants to play he needs to anyway
right exactly so that even even if you
didn't notice it there's a good chance
he plays yeah I can gates do so so let's
see what a ramirez's ideas after that so
of course the point now is that if it
repeats h3 we can just take with the
King on a3 looks a little scary to have
our King up on h3 but it's only
temporary and that is a piece so that
would be terrible
one idea with this move Knight d7 to e5
he's really provoking f4 maybe maybe
Ramirez is thinking that I mentioned it
before that he could bring his knight to
d4 so that after a move like f4 he could
secure the knight on c6 but this is
really getting dicey now because f4 f5
type of attacks really start to become
attractive for the first player that's
right with the f7 square possibly a
target and a potential f6 move even
coming into play so yeah it's kind of
interesting let's see what Ramirez is
going to do after what we think the
natural response here is just King 282
what can I be here besides your knight
to be for idea how is provoking at for a
good thing
well exact
so indeed goddamn I say hey listen I
don't want this night on recycling
itself back oh and he played King to
each one so none of the above not
beneath a king on h2 where I guess you
just felt that on each one it was even
slightly safer but we are thinking about
putting out an h1 is that there could be
a potential temple gainer later with
something like Queen d7 now of course
Queen B salmon fails to Knight to b6
that's right
King h1 interesting but that's why they
usually play h2 just cuz it fortifies
that pond even if it's not possible now
later in the game it might be nice to
have that pawn strengthened whereas
having the King on h2 doesn't seem to
have a lot of drawbacks except in your
line now in 94 is prevented because we
can simply snatch the night
there's no jack no wonderful discovered
check on three squares even here you
have oh you know you don't have anything
and I think not good enough for her
pieces
h1 sidestepped any possibilities of 94
again saying to his young opponent okay
you're doing fine young man but what are
you going to do now show me your counter
plate and for Ramirez it gets a little
bit harder he as we know he wants to
draw the game so he starts looking for
forcing lines but this is not a position
where tactics or combinations are an
ascendancy quite the reverse
it's it's a deep deep strategic fight
trench warfare as we might say and there
are no forcing lines and gotta miss
boning the critical moments of the
battle we do have a move Maurice what do
we have he played rook C to be eight
rooks e to be eight setting up a
potential b5 which actually doesn't work
right here because I have to capture and
then f4 and the rook is really placed
well for that night so in fact not
really doing anything with that last
move and that's was that was the danger
I agree with everything you just said
yes Chomsky with King h1 is saying I'm
not gonna do too much you're never going
to do anything and if I just keep
playing a pace
and you're gonna be looking for moves
that don't even exist what does rugby a
do if B 5 is not playable so I would
expect something like a Bishop to e3
right now and f4 is is always in the
cards and counseling in fact has played
another move Knight to c2 quite
interesting that he chose that move
Knight back to c2 instead I wonder what
the the possibilities of b5 now entail
well what one possible move that were PA
does set up in addition to b5 is a
possible Queen d7 idea because now
Knight b6 no longer wins in exchange and
h2 I mean h3 is is now in take and then
we have to analyze the ramifications of
King H to Bishop takes h3 [ __ ] takes h3
and Knight f3 check right so of course
there are other ways to defend the H
pawn but he needs to would be the most
harmonious look so that could be an
interesting a point that Ramirez was
trying to make with rook b8 that maybe
in the future he can now try to take all
that point on age 3 true but keep in
mind that knight on e5 does not have a
secure square so that the move F to F
for black knight on e5 is going to need
that retreating squared to d7 so it's
not that easy for for black to setup the
threat that you want to set up a bishop
takes h3 you could do Queen c8 but then
after f4 it's our bishop on e6 that
might end up being bereft of squares
correct and I don't like that for the
second player but Maurice made a very
good point here I mean the move rook b8
was really had the straightforward
intention of b5 he didn't wait to be
separately United e7 was played Queen to
d7 was played oh my goodness okay for
what son time bishop there's f6 with the
night f7 or Bishop h3 immediately just
takes on e5 so this plan here playing
that would cost black apiece
no real compensation there so f6 would
probably be forced but doesn't that cost
me black
pawn captures captures simply the very
simple capture here III isn't take at
the end oh you mean after this I see
what you you're saying that is correct
Jen I stand corrected their tactics
there I mean as we see before when we
look at these like capture capture
capture lines you always got to look at
for the I'm nagging in between moves so
well I'll tell you what I still like
this very much for white
maybe we just step back with a bishop if
you're forced to stick to retreat the
night I'm not saying you are maybe take
on h3 because we might have a g5
trapping move around on that's right
something to think about is about g4 and
this bishop comes settles nicely I might
add on this g3 square r-e reinforcing
our King very pleasant position for my
absolutely big attacking chances
therefore I'm not sure f4 f6 Bishop h4
though what about bishop taste h3 well
know after f6 insert your f6 first and
then after Bishop h4 maybe capture on h3
here okay yeah no you wanted to play
something with a g6 g5 I mean I see your
can make it a lot of pawns for its move
it a bit of a mess huh well I would be
frightened to death yeah Wow something
of this nature not only that were we
we're down upon here also yeah guys if I
may of the move of the tournament was
mission with the idea of a venture over
was the choice he's keeping the position
under control and three and remember and
then Ramirez played his knight back to
d7 to challenge that night and calm ski
playing the right ideas dropped his
knight back to d5 no trades except the
ones I like that's right definitely
considering the situation here and now
if uh if Ramirez tries to backtrack and
play Knight f6 situation has changed a
bit but should be six is now on the menu
as mentioned the one small small target
and blacks position potentially weak
squared
six obviously in this case gada is
eyeballing that v6 square but I loved
that suggestion of the computer and a
very difficult one for the human being
to lead with the Jeep on it's so common
for white to lead with the f-bomb that
that blue g4 just expanding on the
kingside stopping any Bishop takes h3
ideas and as a preparatory blow for f4
that looks like that would have given
Alejandro serious serious problems to
consider mention f-word cell also looks
very threatening as well so so quiet
right still very relentless pressure
here for sure when you have the clock
times now displayed and by popular
demand at us chest jams I think we got
about 50 questions for glad times it
just goes to show that a viewership for
this exciting playoff yes it's
definitely increasing we love the CDs
rapid playoffs for all the marbles it's
a it's a lot of fun though of course
it's extremely nerve-wracking for the
players and their fans absolutely and we
have a different approach
finally a different approach by Ramirez
he has played the move Knight d7 to c5
blocking the view of the bishop to that
b6 square in some ways we earlier the
knight was on e5 we thought it was
provoking the move f4 now that the night
is on c5 it's protect provoking pardon
me a potential b4 gotta let's play kg
he's kept all the pieces on the board
Maurice is a big fan of this strategy by
white now it's time to play something
concrete and it's either going to be f4
and f5 or maybe something like be 4a 4b
five consequences for vote for both
actions of course but definitely a well
played game so far by both sides in that
you know Bofors sticking to the strategy
Ramirez
really evening the
the clock disadvantage by quite a bit
right he started off the game with 19 to
45 now it's 20 to about 12 right so if
this gets even and he's got the draws
obviously it's a clear advantage for
ribiriz even if he has a slight divan
and disadvantage on the board right and
finally and dare I say at last gada is
the first one to make a commitment this
isn't a bridge burning or anything like
that but he has made the determination
that the key battle area is going to be
on the kingside and in the center this
move f4 is a clear setup for the
advanced f4 f5 black very often in these
positions plays f5 himself in order to
prevent the advance and then after a
capture either a capture with a pawn or
with the bishop at least in this case
the knight on c5 could swing to e4 still
I do like White's advantage in space and
I just absolutely we go to move from
Ramirez he has played b5 and Maurice has
some thoughts on that now that is the
kind of move of a desperate man he needs
to do something because he's getting
stepped on slowly and I think that this
move will probably cost him the
championship we've got to handle this
right that move f-4es is a kind of move
that says I'm may be threatening f5 you
think I'm threatening it 5 but I'm also
squeezing you make sure you don't have
any moves whatsoever and Ramirez decided
I can't just sit here anymore I need to
make a move and the computer says b5 is
bad doesn't it it makes the disadvantage
even worse for him and it likes now
charging ahead with white it felt that
you open the opening of the game is
going to favor the side with space and
and that the better develop pieces you
can see that white has the chances here
because of his great pieces it wants to
take on b5 in charge ahead with f5 to
prove a real advantage wow I just
noticing that this rook is nicely placed
on the C file hoping to take advantage
of something
those two nights the rook on b8 it's a
little bit passive here of course black
garden has what he wants hopes is a
freeing events but this f5 move you sure
you certainly don't want to capture that
pawn which really does open up that
Catalan fianchetto Bishop but stepping
back mmm-hmm
this really has this is very very
passive now ideas of Bishop age six and
a potential for Bishop takes g7 f6 type
of attacks White hasn't made any
investment he hasn't sacrificed anything
right and why did capture on b5 got a
captured on beef I quickly 8x b5 and now
this moment that hey f4 f5 what else to
do
you don't want black to just simply
maintain his Knights on these squares
you want to type try to exploit them and
f4 f5 looks like the way to do it
no Ramirez has been in the defensive
this entire match even with the white
pieces got a outplayed him in the
opening and Ramirez scored a draw so
it's just it's more of that same pattern
gotta attacking Ramirez defending is he
gonna be successful in this game
well gotta attacking Ramirez defending
successfully has been the story of this
playoff and Maurice more thoughts from
you I was just sitting here looking at
this move f5 that just got played gotta
is now decided it's time to charge down
the board he's playing precise chess
power chess and Ramirez needed to think
about the situation his collapse gonna
start ticking now yes because they're
not really many good choices if he
trades off the division for the night
and pawn takes his knight will find this
great square on e5 but white will play
Knight before even Knight d4 is not a
bad place but b4 is great too and now
you've got to start thinking man what am
I gonna do white has all the space in
the world the two bishops he's
flattening him like a pancake in this
position so black has to be very careful
because his position looks like it's
getting significantly worse and the
computer has him now at a half a pawn
this
advantage which anymore mistakes that
could go bigger plus he's down on time
so Ramirez fans right now watching
clutching their fists quite tightly
because this is not really looking good
for him
no that's right I mean white better on
both sides of the board right we can
make sense to play on the queenside and
as you pointed out very few defenders
left on the kingside another the Knights
have departed the Queen's not in the
game just that Bishop one g7 defending
the King and not a lot of counter play a
more complicated defense it would appear
than his other defenses in this
tournament and we have seen this
exchange of bishop for night night and
your move Knight before it looks was
played attacking the c6 square and
defending the d3 square an outpost
Knight not normally where you see an
outpost night right on before right but
it can't be attacked by a pawn and
Knight to c6 would also unleash the
extra powers of that Bishop on g2 which
myself on d5 one day started interrupt
eyes the computer is going gaga now it
says white is up to 0.71 and blacks best
line Queen a5 and give away the pawn on
c5 it doesn't like blacks position at
all and who would blame I'm trying to
get a little bit a counter play I'm
making white give up one of the best
pieces on the board in order to defuse
some of it and it doesn't look didn't
did he play Queen i5 he did he did play
Queen a5
Wow continuing is a sharp defensive
alert right I mean you just didn't want
to get smashed right the alertness
factor from Ramirez continues to impress
it's not everybody who would be
flippantly giving God a calm ski upon in
an Armageddon game for the u.s.
championship title but recognizing that
there was like a boa constrictor python
effect that God was pressing in the
position this was the right move to try
to get counter play I do agree by
capturing the pawn on c5 you know your
opponent offers you upon you
you take it and you have what was that I
was gonna ask about Knight to c6 just
just because it's a forcing forcing
variation here that we've been looking
at okay so we wouldn't get this trade
and I'm not a hundred percent sure I
need to take this in the knight on c6
that's the problem yeah okay eight and
then we got eight and then then we got
an issue on b2 so we go back God had
said okay I'm gonna take what my
opponents offering me and he's taken
twice on c5 and there is a move that I
personally would find very disturbing
if I were white and that move would be
ninety three so that trading I think is
in blacks best interest and what's
really in blacks best interest is quite
frankly getting a bishops of opposite
color the then whites advantage of the
pond gets reduced I'm not saying that he
did capture on c5 and it looks like
Ramirez is also made a response and I
think Maurice had something bad about
all this well the computer loves your
movie eyes you were right on point
ninety three was the way to go to
minimize the advantage get the opposite
colored bishop so the correct way to
play it didn't like night before because
of this Queen a5 idea transferring into
the possibility of the opposite colored
Bishop ending it preferred Knight d4
with all the same pluses and stopping
that move Queen to a5 so a little
inaccuracy by Tomsky but a missed shot
by Ramirez 93 probably with a shocked
calm ski if that had landed on the board
so we see again that he's missing moves
that move there would have really been a
surprising one going into an ending that
really wasn't that much better for white
clearly better but that opposite called
Bishop position we know could have led
to very defensive possibilities great
defensive possibilities for black but
that's all history now and we have this
position on the board I mean seven point
work to c8 we're gonna be to see a
repeat eight to see eight well trading
pieces isn't isn't the worst thing that
can be fall black in this position now
how on earth can camp ski make hey how
about this for an idea rook
rook takes d6 throw that pawn up the
board and in case of a capture let's try
to entomb that Bishop which I don't like
that Bishop on g7 is a nasty nasty piece
and if we can get the bishop to go
defensive then something perhaps like
Queen d4 it's a positional pawn
sacrifice with the idea of one day maybe
not an immediacy but one day just
occupying the d5 square the materials
even but I like the activity of whites
pieces yes and God I can see now on
thought still has almost twice as much
time as his opponent but the situation's
even in your bed he's getting close to
14 minutes Alejandra is still at nine
minutes
so yeah the time situation equalized me
but why keeping the advantage on the
board right well for the moment this
queen is so darn annoying you know
pinning that night that was why I lashed
out with that rook c8 d 6f six idea I'm
just thinking of ways of trying to break
the pin another possibility is that we
could take take take take and break the
pin in another way going this direction
Queen f4 I'm still protecting the night
I'm opening up the possibility of knight
c6 eyeballing this pawn on f7 we're take
c8 and we're taking eight pawn takes g6
awkard and also Ramirez has recaptured
with the H pawn Queen f4 on the board
tying down that knight in defense of a
f7 as you anticipated whoops my arrows I
gotta get a bad arrow in every single
time but the knight on e5 does indeed
defend f7 and that's why the move knight
c6 has got a concern a Ramirez again the
times 14 minutes for gotta looks like
Mother Nature is giving him call pacing
or pacing and things are really heating
up as it all comes down to what's going
to happen over the
next 20 minutes US Champion about to be
born that's right that's pretty amazing
to me that he got up in this critical
situation
mother nature should have called like
before now just just several minutes
could pass or at least a minute could
pass if he did walk out the room we're
not getting any camera angles showing
that but he certainly is doing really
well right here he's up upon clear and
that night about to go to c6 that's
gonna be a huge problem from a rip from
a Ramirez right now and and the computer
says 0.894 white point point eight nine
almost a full pawn giving some nod to
the bishop our opposite color position
but certainly you don't want to be black
in this position here and I actually
think quick getting up might even be
another bit of a tactic you know this
point sometimes when you're sitting
there your opponent feels you feels your
presence and so you move but if you
leave and just let them stew for a
second they could spend a lot of time
because they're stuck in their own
thoughts and this might be the tactic
that comm skis playing right now it's
just going away from the board and
letting his opponent stop and think for
himself as though he was sitting in his
living room looking at this position but
he ain't in his living room he's on the
stage at the US Championship and you
can't think for too long you're gonna
have to make a move indeed and somebody
asked on art on Twitter what would have
happened if both players would have made
the same exact bid in the final game the
answer is that the arbiter would flip a
coin to see which which I got black and
draw odds of course it's very rare for
that to happen because they do have the
option to bid minutes and seconds which
turned out to be quite important in this
bidding process since it was within just
15 seconds of each other right 1945 for
Ramirez and 20 minutes forgot a Kamsky
that's why Ramirez is playing black and
has draws in this army giving game the
last game of the US Chess Championship
we can finally say it right the final
game of the u.s. sudden-death and here
the more I'm looking at this position
actually the more I appreciate the pawn
I always do appreciate having the extra
pawn but in
this particular case is this knight on
c6 that's hanging like the sword of
Damocles over blacks position because if
white is able to eliminate that knight
on e5 in combination the concert these
this battery on the F file is simply
huge and there is no chance that Knight
takes c6 d takes c6 could be allowed
that passer would decide the game
definitely in goddess favor the problem
for Maris
yeah this is the natural human move to
put the Bishop on f6 nicely blocking the
F file saying hahaha but guess what bang
d5 d6 not only opens up this bishop but
opens up a path to the d5 square for
white tonight and suddenly every single
piece of whites is coordinating against
blacks King a wonderful attacking
position for white and he has a pawn in
hand that would be killer frankly oh
yeah that looks fantastic oh good pawn
on d5 also does so much I'm supporting
the knight to c6 move and just to show a
potential checkmate Ramirez shaking his
head like this just a potential
checkmate idea in the position for
Kamsky I spoke about it just a brief
moment ago I wouldn't want this criminal
on c6 to get there and if Ramirez did
something like Queen c7 here is a
familiar mating pattern that we've seen
plenty of time in chess move like Queen
h4 Knight take c7 thanks to the fact
that there's no H pawn in the position
blacks king is in trouble
so Ramirez facing a very difficult task
at this moment and check out his time
but a move has he played Queen to c7 but
only 4 minutes and 34 seconds on the
clock I'm ski with a pregnant 10 minute
advance
- jomo and up upon as well this is like
a nightmare for Ramirez right now right
and knight c6 looks like the most
natural move on the board I can't
well is there other ideas ideas of h4 h5
just to try to bust open the fortress on
blacks King site that's a thought take
some time is if I were playing a blitz
game it would be very very hard to
prevent my hand from playing knight c6
in this position maybe God is just
concerned I don't know if he should be
or not that in this opposite color
Bishop position a blockade we do have a
move it looks like a 4 was played and
captures so after Queen 27 instead a 4
can to make use of that extra pawn on
the Queen side make some sense it wasn't
the first move that occurred to me but
it does say okay you're the one who gave
me the pawn the extra extra pawn I'm
gonna use it you know the idea could be
a 5 followed by Knight to c6 right a 5/8
you don't want this bond running it down
the board and the moment ago remember
the Queen was on a5 pinning the knight
to the Queen on d2 ruk a8 would be
terrible of course because of d6 with a
discovered attack but I'm saying if this
rook were to leave the protection of its
Queen and then this is a very unpleasant
pin for black as well with 96 so Ramirez
facing all kinds of issues at the moment
and that moved a 4 very cagey and he
he's got something to play with now as
Ramirez opening up his King with a move
f7 f5 a surprising move trying to
protect F pawn permanently but creating
a whole host of other weaknesses
including the g6 pawn to e6 square you
know possible
tactics with d6 in the position in
certain positions is still very
dangerous for Ramirez with very little
time on his [ __ ] we do to get a comment
from the Natalia Pogan Nina yes yes
International master women's Grand
Master and she said classical Soviet
leave the board and allowed the opponent
to take his time tactics from gata
Kamsky is that on how to think like a
grandmaster sometimes it's good to get
up from the board and let your opponent
find all the ghosts that exist in the
position by the way guys you know we
talk about the children of the computer
generation and Ramirez just played a
move that the computer did recommend he
thought f7 to f5 was absolutely the best
move to play right now to have any
chance of holding this game to our human
eyes that whole I mean that looks like
you're opening up your king you're
exposing weaknesses everywhere but it
thought that f7 f5 was the right way to
go shows that guys like me and you yes
you know they're trying to put us out to
pasture with these kind of funky moves
where dinosaurs Maurice I know it don't
I know it but I mean I also know that I
like being pawns up and I I'm willing to
enter this ending now now that I've seen
this move f5
by knight c6 I'm just trying to analyze
the consequences of a trade on c6 and
gotta has played something you did play
Knight to c6 right okay so that was
well-timed I believe now after FTA
captures D takes c6 a capture has and
gotta why are you thinking gotta oh
because he's thinking pardon me he is
thinking whether or not the rook is
worse on c7 maybe he's considering that
he doesn't want the bishop to blockade
so he could be considering the
consequences of trading Queens at once
followed by recapturing on c6 that pawn
is just huge and if he could if he got
it
plate I move like Bishop d5 check and
maybe swing this rugby swing this rook
over a pond
really really Pleasant so got a a big
choice I don't think he has to do that
however i do prefer frankly capturing
immediately because if black captures
who on e5 maybe just simply take with
the pawn so that the bishop isn't
allowed this opportunity to fall back on
this key diagonal stopping the path of
the C pawn but this looks very pleasant
for white a5 a6 Bishop d5 check a7 or c7
it's all coming nicely together and
again the times 10 minutes forgot a
three and a half let's call it for
Alejandro yes and gata Kamsky just
looking to be with a really Pleasant
choice in this position and all the
trumps in the game absolutely
you mentioned Jen that the pawn on g6 is
weak after the move f5
I think Ramirez is going to be forced to
trade Queens because I don't think he's
gonna want to allow anything like Queen
to c4 check followed by Queen to e6
nibbling on this pawn on yes in
opposition though Bishop to e5 looks a
little tricky even with twin c4 check
Bishop e5 I mean I still like white but
after King to g7 maybe the pawn probably
should do that and maybe Kowski didn't
think he needed to open up his King in
any way or over the position because he
did trade by the way he did trade on g7
aid okay tree once and they're going
quickly now Bishop to b5 checking f8
he traded on on see he traded at any one
c6 and now we have this position on the
board and what was played by black and
five I think yifan d5 ooh
I don't think I like that move because
the this these pawns might be block
cated how about Bishop d5 check I did
happen Bishop e5 King F and now the move
of the tournament once again for g4 and
I really really like that I think that
this is simply huge because going gaga
by the way yeah I mean before now
forcing f4 to hold onto the pond
now the problem from blacks point of
view is these pawns on e5 + f4 are very
easily blockaded thanks to the
LightSquared bishop he has a passer on
a4 and c6 and get this a potential
passer over here as well so three
potential passers in the position the
players are moving quickly g4 after g4
he played King g7 and gave up the pawn
on f5 so gada Kamsky two ponds up in an
Armageddon game where he must win is
king d6 being late in Bishop three fish
this is our current position Ramirez
with just two and a half minutes left
and two less pawns it's just finally
looks like Ramirez is not going to be
able to defend one I mean he's been
defending so well but I don't think you
can get out of this rook a7 played I'm
sure ruff g5 is next attacking that
Bishop preparing both Offensive Rookie
six check ideas as well as defensive
rook g4 ideas two ponds up I gotta say
God is winning I just got us a god I got
a guy I got a guy gotta gotta say it
okay what has happened
he played work to g5 he did play rook to
G and I think I said life easy for a
computer move that was a computer's top
choice again a shocker releasing his
bishop hill on the long diagonal it's
still white for choice
White's still winning but still the best
move he hasn't but a a surprising one
true that but okay so
Ramirez is hoping that he could get into
some kind of a rook ending to ponds down
Bishop takes e4 rook takes rook takes I
think that this is just simply winning
what what say you all is this king upon
endgame winning or no it's not so that
was at least what what alejandro had
calculated do we have before me before
played Bishop takes e4
it's totally down three points that I'm
missing something after rook two out
pardon me of course simply rook g6 check
first followed by c7 and then rook takes
so you can't even play rook takes a four
in this position your black is going to
have to play something like Bishop e5
and that happened you did play Bishop
which it was played wow this would be
fine
trying to where they get the pawn on e4
next move three pawns ahead why not just
defend one of them how about Bishop c2
defending this pawn and saying I'll
defend this pawn as well
with rook c6 rook g6 hmm when you try to
round up the pawn anyways the rockwork
a6 true and i don't want to go into
bishops up opposite tell her to pawns up
please see I yeah I guess you could see
seven there but then we could play work
to c6 and hit your Bishop at the same
time and capture the pawn with our rook
right on okay so unfortunately I can't
gada Kamsky trying to find the best
technical move in this position how
about a move like Bishop d3 the idea is
in case of rook takes a four to try to
throw down c7 let's still work a one
check followed by work c1 right right
that's a nice one getting the rook
behind the pawn is key and the endgame
as we've seen instead do something to g6
I believe worked it would've been rook
g6 by by ye okay with g6 and kc5 roxies
rooks g6 King to c5 the computer is
giving black a2
pawn deficit it did not like that last
movement for all that king to c7 was
best King to c5 and things is a real
mistake but still no clear line that
shows exactly how I should win this
position though I suspect there is a way
to win
yeah got on move with a five minute
advantage we are seven and a half
minutes to Ramirez is two minutes and
god I've got to make a decision does he
want to defend this pawn on a4 or try to
keep it with Bishop c2 or does he want
to bring his King in and put all of his
eggs in one basket the H pawn not an
easy choice by any means here a very
difficult effect but let me just try the
move Bishop c2 I like my pawns
I like defending pawns gen you mentioned
a pretty good idea i think i was trying
to set you up for a trap like this that
I may end up simply trapping myself I'm
not sure what you're I play c7
threatening a discovered attack against
your rook as well as making a queen my
trick was that if you drop back with
your rook
I had fishing while I'm not even sure
it's a trick anymore I thought I had a
trick with Bishop e4 and rook c6 we have
a move from God ah
Bishop f3 f3 by Ghana Kamsky now
alejandro under 2-minutes gata Kamsky
relaxing taking a sip of water
okay he's feeling I guess his idea is
that you can't take the pawn on see on a
for thanks to c7 and if the bishop takes
then you've got the move rook check
winning the bishop well good thing we
don't have to see you working bishop
first look in an Armageddon game where
black has drives right that would be
pretty intense but that extra edge fond
of course well um he didn't easy win for
data and on my screen I can see that the
computer approves of this move Bishop f3
bye gotta which but by tactical means
defends the pawn on a4 and gets out of
any captures after rook takes a fourth
the bishop on e4 would not be hanging
and seems like black is under a minute
guys I mean the time has been frozen and
that there we go refreshing he said 55
seconds down three pawns this cannot be
good at all he must lose this position
he must find a miracle way to trade off
everything but the bishop on f3 and the
pawn on h3 right that's the miracle in
game you'd be the right to transpose
into here just I think can't you study
that one when he was about eight years
old exactly just to be clear what what
Jen is mentioning is the classic wrong
bishop and rook pawn ending if black
could give up his rook bishop for whites
rook and pawns a4 and c6 he would be
drawn I don't think he's going to get
that can be fixed plane came out in 19
seconds by the way Knight second he's 19
it looks like on the book no actually
he's just got in five seconds back so
he's at huge five attacking the bishop
and preparing to swing across to the b5
square with a check I think that's gonna
secure the u.s. championship title for
got a nice move very nice move rook g5
in here he's a getting down to his final
seconds work a5 played again basically
playing on the increment the only reason
Ramirez is playing on the increment
because he knows that he's busted
exactly now god I think feels that but
enough White's gonna play King F to 27th
been playing King c7 so that rook is
still in it well maybe just keep going
35 at the end of the variation exactly
at the end of the variation though what
Jen is mentioning is that you could take
take and now after h6 the bishop has to
come back and after h7 the King Bishop
are glued to their squares and whites
King will just dance and we do have 85
King V six on the board
the computers up to four point one three
evaluation for white gigantic edge with
the clock x being
ridiculous ipv6 played okay so now
finally rook takes a for breaking this
pin and gada just loving this moment
he's played really really a great game
and he should be able to reel in the
whole point yes here's a line for you
eight six rook takes a four rook takes
e5 Wow
nasty tactic and after King takes then
c7 and paid for and when that H pawn but
guess what I'm gonna Queen the other
pond that's right
we've got played finishing in style
seeing that variation that the pawn on
e4 is just taboo but Ramirez took it and
now for the five pillars who are this
off dwarf championship title I'm sure he
is I'm sure when when because gada
before he played the move h6
could have played a simple defensive
move like rook g4 but here it is
Holly Hunter Ramirez down to 12 seconds
knows his fate has been sealed he's got
to take the rook right I mean they can't
be our new US chess champion and his
fourth title a fantastic finish to this
I mean we couldn't have asked for more
excitement today at the US Chess
Championship thank you all for watching
and we're actually going to be getting a
grandmaster gata Kamsky down for an
interview here shortly exact no wait
this exhausting day of chess well I mean
I haven't played in this tournament but
after nine days of commentary I know how
the players were feeling I felt really
really low on energy watching the
playoffs especially after game two I
felt great I suddenly had a burst of
energy
adrenaline oh yeah yes
mageddon game really woke me up
completely this was this was high-level
World Championship chess and Alejandro
should be proud of himself I know he's
disappointed but when it really came to
it got a camp Ski world-class player
that made him the Challenger to the
World Championship emerged and a great
game for a rapid game I mean that's
amazing to play that kind of high level
game and even finish it in style with 65
with just a 45-minute game and with the
stakes being so high yeah I mean Becky
might have been better than some of his
regular guy intro game I'm telling you
he wasn't so convincing even when he was
going through his winning streak of 4-0
folks seemed to be gifting him points
but today he really really earned it a
great win by God a camp ski and Mike
congratulations
welcome to the four-time US Championship
club exactly yeah sir Sarah won also a
four-time us jazz champion and we're the
congratulations are rolling in regatta
can't ski cocaina other top players here
are just really excited the live
audience at the st. Louis chess club and
he's just getting set up for his
interview with a grandmaster Ashley
right now so we're excited to you guys
all hearing you know with this win you
want also $30,000 first prize and the
prestige and honor of being US Champion
uh honor he'll will carry for an entire
year and Nakamura is smiling exactly
yeah
Hikaru called it he said that God was
gonna win and wanted him to win and was
rooting for him to win all the way so
magnificent performance by God accounts
ki Maurice
yes I'm here with the 2013 US Chess
Champion gata Kamsky your fourth win
first of all congratulations thank you
how does it feel right now in the
aftermath of what was a really titanic
struggle against the underdog Ramirez
well I was almost held I cook like we
were equals I mean
whatever I did he always came up with
the country move and I was starting to
get really nervous and then of course
I'm sure he missed a lot of
opportunities in this final game to
almost equalize but you know we played
until the last move and it wasn't clear
until the last move will happen now the
first two games were cagey you hadn't
won a game by the way I've you know we
had to point this out you didn't want to
like six tries does that ever happen to
you in a US Championship when's the last
time that happened to you
okay I don't want to think about that so
what was your mindset going into this
last game also he outbid you you said
twenty minutes he said nineteen forty
five is that correct yeah how did that
feel when when you found out that you
did our bit well first we also discussed
the increments because there was a
possibility that we could play without
increments so I realized once we have
increments the time difference is
smaller because of course every move he
gets a 10 or 5 seconds 45 seconds you
have 5 seconds so basically you can plan
the increments until the time travel but
yeah I remembered my bidding protest
against the showman you're a while back
and I thought I'd have chosen 25 minutes
at that time this time I decided to be
more sure and pick 20 minutes but I you
know it was kind of funny when he showed
up was 19 and 40 so you definitely
wanted to have black in that situation
it would be nice to have black of course
because you know very solid and he's
also very solid in a way we're both you
know the players and whoever tries to
get through is real difficult by the way
you mentioned that you didn't realize
that you were playing for $10,000
difference you thought applies the
prices would be split down the middle
how's it feel to Noah
yeah extra 5 grand just jumped in your
pocket well the money is always nice but
of course to me it was more important to
finally win a game because right now I
before the game I didn't feel like I
deserved to win because the way my games
went and I had five draws and wish I
miss probably two or three wins and the
way the record goes and I consider
myself to be one of the strongest rival
players in the world not to be like
completely over optimistic but still and
two draws in the rapper's will be
disappointing for sure so in this game I
had to go and win and then I told myself
you know Gaara
you can't make anymore drawers you know
you gotta win so indeed you were forced
to it in that last game exactly we saw a
little bit of shock on your face when he
played them on Brooke g2 to draw the
second game that came as a big surprise
to you and ending that you know of
course since you were 12 years old no I
have seen this movement but I I mean I
went up to this end game thinking that
it'll be winning then of course I had
similar endgame against the young pony
and he didn't define crackling but this
guy knew so you know I was like I can
get this guy you know like whatever I do
he's always like Houdini you know what
do you think of his prospect do you
think he's just playing well this
tournament or that he's actually risen
in strength somehow to another level
welcome the way he played against me I
could feel that do you know it's a
different immunised I played a year ago
definitely so in a way it's good you
know I'm happy now you had this comment
at the very first round of the
tournament you said that the young
players would be slaughtered this
tournament taking that back because it
looks like they really acquitted him
some was Kaitlyn trough got a GM norm
right 17 I got an I am norm it looks
like they never said they will be
slaughtered I just said they're gonna
try really hard and push for a win and
that that's what I was looking for and I
said that I'll try to give my bass back
you know and I was really happy to see
these guys you know they kicked our ass
they are definitely coming back and not
one final question for you this is your
fourth title you entered a very elite
group of players including our very own
yasss erawan what does that mean to you
well to be honest you know the title the
first time that I want here the second
title you know that was like a very
special to me you know and right now the
third and the fourth title it is it
makes me happy of course but it also
makes me sad you know because you know
anyway I was hoping if somebody else
would become a champion you know some of
the younger players but I just wasn't
going to you know go away without a
fight and hopefully next year they will
be a new champion why now tell me why
that is I have to ask because you know I
have like only a couple of years left in
me of playing chess and I just want to
see while I'm still playing you know
that there
young incoming grandmasters coming and
they'll be blank
entering elite just like Hikari did go
so far is the only current do it and
I've been playing just now since
American for eight years now and only
nucky car so and I think it's time for
somebody else to come in awesome very
gentlemanly of you but in the meantime
you are the 2013 year's champion
four-time champion certainly putting
your name in the record books of chess
history congratulations once again thank
you the 2013 US chess champion gata
Kamsky a fantastic achievement back to
you Jenna yes many congratulations to
Ghana Kamsky and so modest and wonderful
thinking about the future of us Jessie
our absolute and that was the whole
point
in fact of these 2013 US Chess
Championships was here at the st. Louis
chess club the the entire concept but
the whole wildcards was to give these
young chess players
Cayden Sam Conrad
sera opportunities to face the best in
the United States gain experience gain
confidence and it worked marvelously
well better than anybody could expect in
the end our number one seed did win but
I just am so happy that I was a part of
this whole world a US Championship I was
about to say world us championships
because it was really a fantastic event
Jen special thanks to you you've been
terrific hostess and Maurice are always
very special to work with Maurice I
enjoyed it very much
so just a shout out to everybody who
made it all possible thank you so very
much yes I want to take a special
opportunity to thank all of our
listeners including from all over the
world Norway chess
we even had grandmaster Nakamura the
2012 champion watched this playoff in
between beating world champions that was
pretty exciting and also thank of course
the people who made this livestream
possible spectrum Studios headed up by
Randy Singh field Macaulay Petersen
always doing a fantastic job yes we
definitely couldn't have done it without
him right
right hermanni all these controls we've
also got the staff at the st. Louis
chess club headed by Tony rich and joy
Bray not only doing everything for the
players to make a bear tournament better
but also making sure that this ran
smoothly you want to thank all the staff
here at the world chess Hall of Fame as
well and of course Fox Sports Midwest
who believed in chess and I hope that
they will continue in fact we're gonna
see the the special on May 25th 6:00
p.m. Central Time and it's going to also
air in additional time so be sure to
check your local listings and find the
recap show and which is going to include
a lot of behind the scenes highlights
and interviews additionally of course
the arbiters Frank Waterloo pan Carroll
directly Alex Marlar and 20 rich again
finally we always have to give a shout
out to the sponsors and the founders of
the Chess Club and the Hall of Fame Rex
Sinquefield and Jeanie Sinquefield
fantastic things they've done for chess
and the fifth in a row u.s. Chess
Championship and US Women's here in st.
Louis and it's just been getting better
and better and again thank you to
everybody and again Maurice you the man
that's right thank you to Maurice Ashley
and all is a great commentary and
interview throughout these two weeks
here in st. Louis work with you this was
a fantastic team it was so much fun
amazing we had to work an extra day and
it was more fun than the first nine days
so are really a pleasure for me to be
with this commentary team indeed you
know it's a good gig when you're excited
to work an extra day that's right and of
course for that we've got to thank our
players for all of their exciting games
even when they weren't playing for the
championship we got thrills and chills
in this championship special shout out
to sha blob and Kristensen for their
remarkable achievement decisive games of
18 decisive games between the two of
them that's fantastic you kept everyone
guessing and congratulations to Irina
crash our US Women's Champion and gotta
Kamsky our US chess champion nine titles
now between the two of them absolutely
thrilling
yes and I wish we could we we we've we
had more games to analyze but finally I
think it's about time for us to sign off
and once again this is Jennifer jihadi
and I'm signing off with Grand Master's
yasser sarah Juan and Maurice Ashley
after two amazing weeks of jazz
[Music]
[Music]